up guys
um I just did another morning coffee
thought video but today I'm just in the
mood to talk I'm gonna talk in mood
no one here wants to listen
so I'm gonna talk to my camera so
there are two things I'm going to tell
you
the first is three pieces of advice I
forgot to put in the last video I
thought of them after the last video if
you look at my last coffee thought I
said advice my parents gave me
um and I forgot to put this in the
second part of the video I'm going to
tell a crazy crazy story of something
that happened to me like this is one of
the maddest things that's happened to me
in my life so
but first I'm going to tell you guys the
three pieces of advice so the first
piece of advice that I forgot to say so
this is advice number 14 there's 13 my
last video is okay
so there are times in my come up Journey
where there was someone that gave me a
piece of advice and this was coming from
a respected person okay this was someone
that I looked up to a lot that had the
knowledge in the field that had the
wherewithal but my gut told me that they
were wrong and I'll give you an example
so I had someone very knowledgeable in
the field telling me that posting 18
times in one day is too many
[Music]
apparently that's going to be annoying
for my viewers and I have gotten some
feedback from some of you that it's
annoying but at the end the way I don't
give a [ __ ] and I'm sorry I'm sorry guys
but when I see my Subs going up my money
going up My Views going up it's it's
hard why would I
why would I listen to you my fans are
like modern women they don't know what
they want and
when I told my dad I'd say okay so and
so said to do this but I I don't think
this is right my gut is telling me this
is wrong and he said so what smart
people can be wrong too
and you can't just because someone's
smart and maybe they know more than you
take their advice into consideration and
they might be right but if you make a
decision and your gut is telling you
that
it's the wrong decision like stay true
to yourself and stay true to what you
like what you believe because I would
rather
make a decision that like I I truly
believe in and be wrong then go off of
someone else's advice and be right and
there's a lot of advice that I took from
people that knew more than me a ton that
I took but when I disagreed with it and
it didn't make sense to me I would go my
own way and just be like you know what
if I'm wrong we can go back later we can
try to fix it later and that's just the
mentality like
if you hire someone and they suck you
can just hire someone else later if like
they're like I just have this mentality
that any mistake can be undone and any
mistake can be fixed so like let's say I
didn't do 18 post 18 times in one day
and it was wrong and everyone was
stopping subscribing like I could just
stop doing it
and that's the thing like just because
you respect someone it doesn't mean
they're right and you can disagree with
someone's opinion and do your own thing
and they may be wrong okay two
um don't take talking [ __ ] personal I
think women as women we do this more
than men but this is just something I've
learned in my life because as women we
vent
we we vent okay it's not a fun fact
about us but it just is like we get
frustrated we vent to each other it's
just normal and as much as it's not a
fun fact and as much as I try to keep
other people's names out of my mouth I'm
just being honest when at some point
your friend or your family is probably
going to say something not so nice about
you and at some point you've probably
said something not so nice about them
that maybe you didn't mean that maybe
you're just frustrated so you know what
give them the benefit of the doubt it's
one thing when they're telling your
secrets across town but if you find out
from a mutual friend that they're
talking to it's like
personally I've just in my life given
people the benefit of the doubt because
a lot of times they come back around
even if they're mad like they'll come
back around and that's what I think of
long term like when people are like I'll
never talk to you again it's just gonna
let them come back around
um
three this actually isn't
advice but this is kind of you know I'm
gonna tell my story in the next video
because I feel like these should be
separate videos but
so this advice is not for my parents but
it's actually from listening to men talk
now a lot of people on the channel will
say to me you don't have a relationship
you're single and I'm like yeah that's
that's totally fair well you're a modern
woman and how would I describe myself I
would say yeah traditional women were
married under the age 22. they did all
this stuff I am a modern woman and it's
unfortunate I wish I wasn't but I I
think unless you're a virgin sorry but
it doesn't mean we can't work to be more
traditional and work to be more of what
men want and one thing I didn't
understand in a previous relationship I
had is
my boyfriend at the time would come home
and I would be at his apartment I we
didn't actually live together but I was
just sometimes I just chill there he
didn't care and um
when he would come back I would be like
so excited to tell him about my day like
and
you know uh what I realized is guys like
when guys say they want peace what they
want is they want to and you guys can
correct me if I'm wrong but they want to
come home to silence
and this advice I did this on my last
show they want to come home and they
want you like like you have to wait for
him to talk to you first and the other
thing is they just want a clean house
some food
and
respect
and sex obviously but
and I didn't realize like
men don't really ask for that much and
women will bite tooth and nail to give
that to them like it's funny because all
the things that men wanted when I really
sat and I really listened to what men
want I was like wow that's really not
that crazy like it's not that crazy to
ask for consistent sex from your wife
it's not that crazy to ask for a
consistent food a clean home right most
guys are understanding like they don't
expect it to be perfect but when I was
really thinking about it I'm like every
time I bring up those things to women
like their head always goes to the
extreme like it's like well what if I'm
not in the mood what if this this and
this and I'm like well in general
shouldn't you have sex with your husband
and then it's like well shouldn't you
cook for your husband in general and
they're like well
but I work and like but
and like how many how many girls really
know their boyfriend or their husband's
favorite meal
how many have really taken the time to
like get to know what he likes and
you know I think
I'm not saying I've always been perfect
about this but it's really interesting
to like hear what the men want and when
I tell the women what the men want like
how hard we fight it when we could have
a better relationship we could get along
with men better
if we just understood what they were
saying
um
yeah so that's like my two cents
um
it's kind of mad like this whole thing
is kind of mad
um
I I have a crazy story for you guys but
I feel like I should wait for a third
video because I just think this needs to
be its own video because this is the
maddest thing that's ever happened to me
well
I've done a lot of crazy one of the
maddest anyways like the video
um stay tuned for a video coffee thought
evening tea number three
in a minute I'll talk to you later bye